en 2003 Ruslan Ponomariov champion du
monde feed est devenu le premier joueur
d'échec à perdre parce que son téléphone
avait sonné durant sa partie allô alors
il est beau protester se plainre auprès
des arbitres refuser de signer la
feuille de match il a bien eu parti
perdu avec l'accord signé anecdote
amusante l'année d'après le grand maître
agrest contre qui c'est arrivé a lui
aussi perdu une partie parce que son
téléphone a sonné on ignorant en
revanche chez ponom marov qui l'appeler
pour se venger allô allô c'est toi en
tout cas depuis les téléphones sont
proscrits des salles échec puisque les
affaires de triche ont été mises en
lumière la chasse au
Pipo avec notamment la célèbre et triste
histoire du Grand Maître Igor rosist
surpris dans les toilettes avec son
téléphone